new twist in a story we've been closely
following here on CBS morning's a surge
in so-called romance scams according to
the FBI there is a major new category of
these scams crypto dating scams where
fraudsters convinced people to put their
money into fake cryptocurrency
Investments the analytics firm chain
analysis says more than 7.7 billion
dollars was stolen in cryptocurrency
fraud worldwide in 2021 our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
shows us just how devastating those
scams can truly be
I think the biggest thing that I will
be sad about is not being able to share
anything with her 24 year old Nicole
Hutchinson lost her mother Cynthia in
February 2020. any memories or
experiences after her death Hutchinson
inherited her mother's house which she
sold splitting the proceeds with her
father two hundred eighty thousand
dollars each money she says to help pay
for her 94 year old grandmother's
assisted living and help her and her dad
that was going to be our launch pad for
him to retire easily and for me to start
my life
a new life in California and to start
meeting people there she joined the
dating site hinge she says she soon met
a man named Hal and they became friends
he started asking questions about my
family and my past experiences it was a
connection that felt even stronger she
says when he told her he came from the
same town in China from where Hutchinson
was adopted we kind of bonded over that
soon she says he was telling her about
one of his Hobbies cryptocurrency
investing and he suggested she too could
invest I'm like I've never invested in
my life I don't know anything about
cryptocurrency either so I was very
skeptical not to worry he said in a text
this is my field I can be your teacher
first he told her to create an account
on a legitimate site crypto.com then he
sent her a link and told her to transfer
money there to what he said was a
cryptocurrency exchange platform she
started small but says soon she was
investing larger amounts twenty six
thousand forty nine thousand seventy
three thousand dollars he just kept
saying things alike look at this money
that can help support your family
obviously that's what I've wanted to do
when her account began showing profits
she suggested to her father that he
invest too so he did by December their
accounts showed a combined balance of
1.2 million dollars and Hutchinson
decided it was time to cash out that's
when the site told her before she could
withdraw her money she'd have to pay a
hefty tax bill of roughly three hundred
eighty thousand dollars that's when I
was like something's not right it wasn't
the cryptocurrency Investments weren't
real all her and her father's funds had
gone into the scammers pockets in all
three hundred ninety thousand dollars
stolen I
messed up my life I messed up my Dad's
life she told me that it was all a scam
Hutchinson's father Melvin and all I
could do was just hug her and tell her
it's okay if it's okay and uh it was
hard it was hard because we lost
everything they're not alone a new
report finds just in 2021 cryptocurrency
scam victims lost more than 7.7 billion
dollars anybody that's really trying
hard to get you to invest in
cryptocurrencies has a motive Rich
Sanders investigates cryptocurrency
scams as co-founder of company
cipherblade we asked him to look at
Nicole Hutchinson's transactions to see
how she was scammed this does seem to be
what's commonly referred to as a pig
butchering scam that's right it's called
a pig butchering scam where scammers
patiently work their victims before
moving in for the kill the name really
comes from the fattening up before the
slaughter in Hutchinson case he found
her money started in those legitimate
cryptocurrency accounts but the links
the crooks told her to transfer the
money to were actually digital wallets
belonging to the scammers and his firm
traced other money going to those fake
addresses too likely he says from other
victims it is easily a 10 plus million
figure
so you're saying conservatively they've
scammed at least 10 million dollars in
your estimation absolutely money he says
likely went to an organized ring of
scammers operating out of Asia who prey
on inexperienced victims I think he
really played off that I was naive and
not knowing anything about crypto
and taking that and running with it
Hutchinson and her father are now living
in his RV I just hope others don't have
to fall for it so if me sharing the
story helps that then I'm so grateful as
for the scammer her father says I hope
that there is some justice in life
and he reaps his
we don't know who the scammer or
scammers were of course and that
legitimate site crypto.com warns
consumers to take steps to try to be
sure that any accounts they're moving
money into are legitimate now the
company says it takes a proactive
approach to threats and immediately
takes down any wallets online linked to
a scam that dating site hinge also told
us it takes fraud very seriously and has
trained content moderators out looking
for this sort of stuff but Nate it's
really consumerable where you have to be
very careful
and I don't know everything about crypto
but I do know that money can disappear
and it can be lost forever is there a
chance for her and her father to get
their money back
it's not looking very hopeful for them
to get any of that money back she has
reported this to the police she even
hired a private detective to look into
it but what the experts will tell you is
that typically once the money is out of
your control and into the scammers
control it's gone in fact when we had
the experts look at her transactions
they actually looked at Associated
transactions as well and they think tied
to these scammers literally they found
over 20 million dollars lost
mind-blowing Anna thank you so much this
is a valuable story because crypto is so
hot right now and everybody wants to get
involved because they have a fear of
missing out yeah they think I don't want
to be left behind for something that
seems so lucrative but you could see
where she would fall for it because you
see in your balance it's growing which
was a fake account which was a fake
account but if you see 1.2 million
dollars you're like Dad come on we got
to invest crypto feels so technical that
you're grateful that this friend quote
unquote is helping you guiding you
through it and everything very clever of
the fraudster to say he was from the
very same Village she's from in China
say something go ahead go ahead I would
just say checks and balances you know if
like you said if something seems too
good to be true it probably is but if
you have multiple people
um with multiple levels of expertise
checking on your Investments then maybe
somebody could say wait a minute there's
one two three maybe even four red flags
do not do this I just want to say kudos
to Dad because I don't know many fathers
who would would respond the way he did
to say look it's going to be okay we'll
be all right most a lot of people would
be very angry be very angry at her and
be very certainly very angry he
responded with a hug that's amazing no I
think that that's and I think situations
like this are what um gofundme's are
really for so hopefully people can band
together and help them get back on their
feet it was a great story